Fantasy sports leagues
are wildly popular.
You can play fantasy football,
fantasy baseball,
fantasy basketball.
You name it,
there's a fantasy league for it.
And now it's gotten so crazy
that it's crossed over
to people who don't even care
about sports.
Uh-oh.
Who has Peyton?
Tommy, is that you?
Yep, that's me.
What'd he do?
The offer on the house
that he loved was accepted!
Yes! Peyton Cariole
is moving his wife and kids
into a nice, beautiful home.
What's that,
40 points?
Yeah!
This could be you
if you played
Fantasy Life League.
Hey, Tommy,
you start Jeremy Ross this week?
Yeah, why?
Looks like he slept
through a street cleaning
and got a $60 ticket.
Minus 10 points!
-Come on, man.
-Whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
That's what you get
for wasting a pick
on a guy
with a drinking problem.
[ Both laugh ]
Fantasy Life League
turns the lives
of the boring people you know
into the most exciting game
on the planet.
Oh, hell yeah.
Judy had a wonderful visit
with her grandkids.
Quality time with
the grandchildren, 20 points.
Eeeeeeeeeeee.
You know what that is?
Eeeeee.
Ask me what that is.
Ask me what it is.
What is that?
That's your flatline,
'cause you're dying.
Eeeeeeeeee.
[ Weakly ]
Take care of my cats.
When your friends
go through hard times,
you'll be right there
with them.
Oh, no.
Guys, Amanda's aunt died.
That's minus 100 points,
and it [bleep] up
my whole season.
And when they triumph,
so will you.
Oh, yes, Mother[bleep]
Jesse just adopted
a rescue dog.
Ooh, my God.
Just look at that [bleep]
cute dog, huh?
That's a terrier mix, bitch!
Oh, my God!
Companionship for Jesse,
25 points for me!
You like that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
When you play
Fantasy Life League,
you don't have to pretend
to be happy for your friends.
Eddie's MRI
came back negative.
Those symptoms
were just due to anxiety.
My man has no
serious health issues.
Oh! That's 30 points.
Damn it!
[ Laughs ]
Hey, hey.
Eeeeee. Eeeeee.
Ask me what that is.
Eeeeeeeee.
And as your friends
move up in life,
you'll move up
into first place.
Are you happy you traded me
Liz for Frank?
Why?
And are you happy you traded me
Eric for Wendy?
Why? Did something happen
with Liz and Eric?
Not much.
They just went camping.
And got engaged
underneath the stars!
-Yes!
-[ Groans ]
Eric loves Liz,
Liz loves Eric.
They want to spend their lives
with each other.
200 points.
I hope she cheats on him.
Well, you better hope
it's not with Rick Roberts,
'cause I got him, too.
The only friends
you'll be jealous of
are the ones
that outsmarted you
in Fantasy Life League.
Yes! Jennifer got the job!
Tommy is the Fantasy Life
champion for this season.
You all are losers,
but it's okay.
[Bleep] y'all!
Y'all suck!
[ Cellphone rings ]
[ Laughs ]
Ooh. It's my boss.
You got a job?
Hello?
Oh, no. Uh...
Tommy got
so into Fantasy League Life
that he started
blowing off work,
and now his boss just called
and fired his ass.
Minus 40 points.
[ Laughter ]
Fantasy Life League.